salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
matière grise nous nous intéressons une
thématique en lien avec le cerveau un
petit peu mon organe préféré dans les
épisodes précédents de la saison une
vous m'avait proposé de parler de la
mémoire ça tombe bien c'est le sujet du
jour bienvenue dans la saison 2 de
matière grise
[Musique]
oh
dans cet épisode vous allez vivre quatre
expériences expérience une dessine au
logis expérience de témoins oculaires
expérience 3 c'est à vous expérience 4
oubliez votre bloc-notes le tout avec la
présence très appréciée de cyrus north
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la mémoire est sûrement l'un de mes
sujets préférés quand on évoque les
possibilités de notre cerveau vous
imaginez on a jusqu'à 100 milliards de
neurones jusqu'à cent mille connexions
par neurones les possibilités de notre
mémoire sont dingues on va simplement
l'explorer pour mieux la comprendre voir
des choses que vous n'imaginez même pas
et bien sûr mieux l'utiliser vous le
savez sûrement mais nous avons plusieurs
types de mémoire certaines sont liées à
la notion de temps et d'autres sont liés
à différents sens dans cette expérience
vous allez pouvoir participer préparer
juste une feuille et un crayon à
proximité pendant que vous allez
chercher ça je vais terminer mon
explication si vous vous éloignez un
petit peu trop de l'ordinateur ou du
téléphone monter le son parmi les
mémoires principal nous pouvons citer la
mémoire d'un court terme c'est une
mémoire limitée dans le temps qui dure
en moins d'une seconde jusqu aux
environs de 10 minutes elle sert par
exemple à stocker des informations
telles qu'un code de porte d'entrée ou
ce genre de choses très rapide qu'on
oublie très rapidement et justement la
mémoire à court terme c'est la porte
d'entrée de la mémoire à long terme
lorsque vous voulez retenir un cours
parker par exemple vous allez le répéter
plusieurs fois pour vous en imprégner
comme on dit pour que ça rentre donc
pour que ça passe du court au long terme
il va falloir l'entretenir et le répéter
la mémoire juste au dessus qui est
étroitement liée de mener à sont toutes
liées c'est la mémoire de travail qui
utilisent ce qu'il y a dans la mémoire à
court terme imaginez que vous êtes au
restaurant choisi c'est ce que voulait
manger dans le menu qu'on vous apporte
sa se range dans la mémoire à court
terme puis vous discutez avec l'ami
qu'est venu avec vous quelques minutes
après le serveur arrive et demande ce
que vous voulez manger la mémoire de
travail pioche la donnée dans votre
mémoire à court terme pour que vous
puissiez répondre aux serveurs
évidemment et ensuite vous allez
reprendre le fil de la discussion avec
votre ami qui lui aussi était stockée
temporairement dans la mémoire à court
terme et enfin avant de passer à
l'expérience j'aimerais vous parler de
la mémoire épisodique
c'est celle qui stocke naturellement ce
que vous vivez vos souvenirs comme la
conversation avec votre ami qui va
rapidement passé dans la mémoire
épisodique
vous n'allez pas vous souvenir de chaque
mot que vous avez prononcé mais vous
allez vous souvenir de la soirée avec
lui c'est grâce à cette mémoire que vous
savez ce que vous avez fait hier ou que
vous pouvez imaginer
la prochaine soirée que vous allez faire
elle peut se projeter elle est accentuée
par tout un lot de facteurs tels que les
émotions positives ou négatives tout ce
que vous ressentez quand vous vivez un
instant précis et maintenant passons à
l'expérience et si vous avez une feuille
et un crayon avec vous tant mieux vous
allez pouvoir le faire avec nos
foies et moi on va parler de mémoire
aujourd'hui et il ya deux secondes avant
que ça arrête tu m'as dit la mémoire
jacky faut pas les mental tout ça ouais
t'as un palais mental ouais bah j'en ai
plusieurs mamans ouais enfin normalement
il ya que toi qui sais mais peuvent
avoir plusieurs tueurs mieux je te
confie dans cette première expérience ce
carton plus magnifique ouais on va se
baser sur une étude qui a été faite en
2018 de l'université de waterloo donc en
gros je vais te donner une vingtaine de
mots auxquels à chaque fois je te
donnerai comme consigne soin d'écrire le
mot soin de dessiner un jour après jour
les rôtir genre non un drop juste créée
au niveau hockey tu va dessiner une
échelle s'il te plaît
[Musique]
ouais on m avait que 4 et le village
mais je me suis un peu d'accord à swing
trop course l'échelle type dessine un
nuage
tu écris le mot le livre suivi du mot
centre
d'accord
d'accord je suis sur le truc en fait tu
es parti sur ceinture ouais on sur la
racine de s'enfuir j'ai honte on peut
leur faire ça ou pas tu peux écrire le
mot valise et ensuite il dessinera une
paire de ciseaux
tu écris le mot hugo suivi du palindrome
kayak qu'est ce qu'un pas mal rob
simmons c'est quand tu as une symétrie
sur un mot quoi comme par exemple enfin
ça peut être une phrase aussi genre
engage ce jeu que je le gagne l'église a
ensuite passé à rattraper du coussin
trois mois je trouve ok tu peux de
signer des lunettes mais ensuite écrire
le mot trompette ok on est à mi chemin
ensuite tu écris le mot fenêtres et
après on va passer à trois petites
phases de dessin un poisson se marchent
une règle il ne fourchette s'il te plaît
dessine et toujours
tu écris les deux mots suivants
télécommande et caméras
ensuite tu dessinera une chaussette
c'est pas mal tu écris au mot piano tu
dessines clé est ce que je suis venu ici
pour souffrir genre et on terminera en
écrivant le mot limaces
et c'est vrai que tu m'a posé une
question de ce que je dois retenir des
choses graves ici c'est une non mais oui
oui mais non en fait le but c'est de
tester juste les différences d'encodage
poker était capacité à rentrer les
choses dans la mémoire travail mémoire
épisodique
okc sémantique dans l'équipe type de
mémoire et c'est exactement ce qu'ils
ont fait durant l'étude de 2018
au moment de la restitution
tu vas me dire tous les maux dont tu te
souviens comme ça spontanément et moi je
vais les entouré ici ok donc dans le
désordre dans l'ordre que tu veux dans
ce qui te fait le plus plaisir mais
j'arrive à pas faire je pense que
l'ordre au total mais ça commençait par
échelle les nuages après je veux dire
li masquer les
télécommandes caméra piano règle 6 au
poisson
attends tu sais que la mémoire de
travail elle retient en général cet item
cette information ouais pour une durée
limitée ouais on a déjà largement passé
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 ils menacent
plus des dessins ou des mouchoirs que
c'est des mots qui moi c'est exact ça
c'est pas un hasard me regarde
effectivement avait trouvé un deux trois
quatre cinq six dessins vers 6 1 2 3 4
mots pourquoi je compte que quatre mots
parce que cintres ne compte pas on en a
tellement parlé en fait tellement une
émotion particulière dessus qu'il est
traité différemment des autres
informations mais tu vois c'est marrant
ce que kayak ouais ça aurait pu tuer
mais pas d'émotions on a parlé des
palindromes etc donc oui effectivement
on retient beaucoup mieux ce qu'on a
dessiné pour plein de raisons la
première c'est que pour dessiner et tu
es obligé de te concentrer donc en fait
obligé de faire ce travail d analyse et
de condensé de le condensé après un vrai
acte créatif où tu joues tu fais marcher
sa motricité bien différemment d'eux que
quand tu écris un mot et surtout pour
dessiner été obligé d'aller chercher
déjà dans tes souvenirs un souvenir
existant va te permettre de le dessiner
tu vois ce que je veux dire quand on
écrit quelque chose il ya un processus
qui se met un peu en place dans le
cerveau depuis qu'on a inventé
l'écriture et le papier surtout pour
noter qui est dans cerveau il reçoit
l'information de je l'écris quelque part
donc je ne pourrais pas le jeu mondial
ça existe quelque part et de la même
manière il une autre étude qui avait
montré que quand tu prends des photos de
tes vacances tu encore moins de
souvenirs parce que ton cerveau c'est
que la photo elle existe dans le
téléphone et compagnie on pourra y
revient c'est intéressant de passer par
le dessin l'acte créatif donc dès que tu
vas chercher une image qui est dans ta
mémoire épisodique la mémoire des souris
du coup mémoire épisodique c'est
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait hier encore
qu'est ce que j'ai mangé hier par
exemple c'est tout chaud ça dure genre
qu'est ce qu'il a fait hier ok qu'est ce
que j'ai mangé hier notamment chez
squire
si on sait nager des ravioles télé truc
les pattes ralala qui se réchauffe en
deux minutes et c'est que si on analyse
exactement comment tu as fait tu as fait
qu'est ce que j'ai mangé hier tout était
rentré dans notre section et après tu as
fait travailler tout tes mémoires
possible pour retrouver vite
l'information de discuter d'un stress et
on a vu ta mémoire procédurale 2 j'ai
fait des tas profil geste en fait pour
revivre le moment et pour tout autour et
active en banque heureusement je t'ai
pas fait qu'est-ce que j'ai fait hier
soir qu'est-ce que j'ai fait hier soir
fait un changement au jeu c'est à genoux
brosser les dents j'aime me brosse à
beaucoup les dents en ce moment
ce que l'on vient de faire est un
condensé vraiment vraiment léger de
l'étude initiale on peut aller encore
bien plus loin montrer une image
fonctionne mieux en terme de mémorielle
que montrer un mot écrit pourquoi grâce
à l'imaginaire imaginez c'est faire
fonctionner sa mémoire épisodique et
vous savez c'est celle qui stocke vos
souvenirs et vous n'avez pas d'efforts à
faire pour mémoriser ce que vous avez
fait il ya dix minutes ou aujourd'hui de
la même manière en dessinant vous
utilisez la partie visuelle de votre
mémoire épisodique un dernier point sur
cette étude ces mêmes chercheurs se sont
demandés comment fonctionner le dessin
sur la mémoire épisodique des personnes
âgées car cette mémoire se dégrade avec
le vieillissement mais pas les régions
visuelles gère cette mémoire ils ont
fait le test avec les dessins à écrire
ou à dessiner et les personnes âgées
restituer nettement plus de modestie
n'est que ce qu'ils avaient écrit dans
la prochaine expérience justement vous
allez être les témoins oculaires d'une
scène de crime est-ce que vous allez
être capable de témoigner ensuite c'est
ce qu'on va faire dans quelques instants
et j'aimerais vous rappeler que comme
toujours matière grise est sponsorisé
par moi même
fabien du coup mais quoi pour le
partenariat
à bien
[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
la mystérieuse disparition de fabien
sauciflard ou est il que fait-il
pourquoi n'est-il pas présent pour cette
partie partenariat c'est ce que nous
allons découvrir aujourd'hui bienvenue
donc cabinet partenariat
alors on va commencer par la phase
d'exploration a et on voit on voit quoi
on voit qu'il est en tournée et oui à
peine singularité fini qu'il est déjà
reparti en tournée dans toute la france
avec son nouveau spectacle en création
et en création c'est quoi en fait ils
sillonnent toute la france dans des
petites salles pour créer son nouveau
spectacle avec vous en toute intimité et
ce qui est bien aussi avec en création
c'est qu'en fait aucune représentation
n'est là même le tour d'un soir eh bien
il est peut-être plus là le lendemain
comme monde et hinder et castets résolu
donc si vous voulez le voir en spectacle
je vous mets juste la liste de la
tournée je vous mets aussi un lien et
des infos en description si vous avez un
doute vous allez sur fabien olicard
point fr a très vite
alors là je m'arrête là dessus parce que
c'est très marrant qu'est ce qu'on peut
voir dans le verbal déjà dans le verbal
on voit que j'ai pas dis à très bientôt
ciao mais j'ai dit à très vite ça lui
c'est une blague une petite blagounette
dont le non verbal voilà on peut voir
dans la posture là que j'ai un petit
sourire mais un petit sourire
bienveillant parce que c'est une petite
manipulation pour vous pousser à acheter
les places pour le spectacle mais parce
que je pense que ça sera bien pour vous
ça va être une bonne chose ça on peut le
voir sur cet arrêt sur images mais par
contre il existe aussi des manipulations
qui sont nocives et pour vous en
prémunir bien je vous conseille tout
simplement ce petit ouvrage lentilles
guide de la manipulation disponible dans
toutes les librairies tous les magasins
je vous le recommande je vous le
conseille merci on continue
[Musique]
soyez attentifs à la prochaine
expérience tout d'abord vous allez me
voir dans le rôle d'un braqueur mais
surtout vous allez être témoin de la
scène seriez vous capable ensuite de me
faire une déposition correct et sous
serment
tu vas être témoin de quelque chose
auquel malgré toi tu es moi je n'ai pas
jéhovah mois samba non sinon seraient 2
pourtant parlé ce matin ça jamais seul
pendant ces vols il est possible
qu'après la police viennent interroger
et te demandent des positions ce qui
s'est passé ok ouais je parle pas fort
c'est pour le braquage
le braquage du catering ah ouais donc je
te dis l'opération main basse sur le
panier gourmand on récupère tous les
bananes les pommes les fraises tout oui
les orange ci en harnais prend aussi
ouais ouais après manger 5 comme ça par
jour c'est bien mais il n'ya pas que ça
en fait j'ai vu qu'ils ont des bières
regarder si c'est avec ou sans
way pour qu'on soit pas dépouiller à la
fin quoi en tout cas on ouvre rien
pendant le braquage non non non je
n'aime pas une grappe de raisin rien
les bouteilles de vin on prend le
champagne on prend ça se trouve en très
très bien ça le champagne et après on se
donne rendez-vous pour moi bien là où tu
sais alors que tu sais si tu sais puis
c'est à midi dix neuf ans la porte
d'entrée ok et soit discret c'est si on
sait que c'est moi on va se dire ok
d'accord
il se vole lui même ce serait un
problème bon à tout à l'heure ok ah s'il
ya des manques tu m'en prends comme ça
fait bien bonjour chris a enchanté un
gentil un braquage a eu lieu ici mais
non si absolument on a volé tout le
catherine de midi à offrir à manger
les serpents dit que vous étiez témoin
de ce braquage de la préparation je sais
pas ça m'intéresse pas mais alors
attention j'ai vu usual suspects si
c'est vous et moi et moi qu'on est juste
ce qui ce qui est autant que je le
saurai j'ai vu quelqu'un donc au
téléphone avec une cagoule et des
lunettes hockey qui est en train de
raconter un complice
ce qu'il fallait faire en fait donc
l'opération ok donc c'est une opération
derrière la main non c'était mainmise
sur le panier gourmand
pour le vol du caire les garnir le
panier gourmand pas et garni peut-être
on a deux affaires en cours dont carey
serait vraiment bien de savoir
précisément si c'est un panier garni ou
un panier gourmand dans mon souvenir
c'est gourmand mais c'est peut-être
garde mais je sais que ça a parlé de
banane ça parlait de fraises ça parler
d'orange aussi et de pommes aussi
pendant et ensuite ça parlait de
différents alcools
la bière alors il y en avait avec ou
sans mais j'imagine ça avec ou sans
alcool il a dit le mot alcool ou pas non
c'est important pour un déclin il a
parlé d'un whisky non il n'est pas prêt
whisky mais il a parlé de vins de
champagne hockey
et
ensuite y'a pas une mangue aussi 1 comme
le psg l'a prononcé le mot fruits c'est
important pour moi non je crois pas non
non je t'assure non mais je crois pas
qu'elle ait ensuite croyez pas
non je crois pas je crois pas il n'a pas
dit le mot banane il n'a pas dit non si
baden baden s'il l'a dit le mot banane
hockey ouais et ensuite il a dit très
clairement que voilà il fallait pas
qu'on sache que c'est lui parce que ce
serait bizarre de se braquer soi-même
d'aquin donc pour moi ça donne quand
même assez un indice assez conséquent ce
jour sur la personne de toute façon si
on voudrait savoir genre il fallait être
là 12h10 à la porte d'entrée ok ce que
ça leur point de rendez vous quoi vous
juriez tout ce que vous avez dit le mot
pomme a été prononcé le mot banane aussi
oui le mot fruits n'a pas été prononcé à
six parce qu'il y avait cinq fruits et
légumes par jour je crois enfin ya eu
cinq fruits et la phrase n'a pas été
terminé ok mais ce truc de fruits et
légumes enfin manger équilibré 5 fruits
machin je pense que si free s'était
enfui a été prononcé ouais oui ce qui
n'a pas été prononcé et ce qui n'en fera
pas un alcool n'a pas été prononcé je
suis quasi sûr pour alcool mais je
compte enfin je pense pas que ça ait
dépensé mais j'ai un doute whisky je
suis sûr que non ok al qods un petit
doute ok donc il ya juste alcool on a un
petit ouais ok aussi ignoré cette
déposition de votre sang ouais ok
débrief tu t'es senti comment way assez
sûr de moi après voilà je suis pas à
l'abri de tromper quoi mais en vrai
c'était c'était très bien il ya une
faille et un moment moi de dire laquelle
après mais ce qui était intéressant déjà
c'était de voir alors vous vous l'avez
pas vu mais entre les deux séquences il
s'est passé un petit peu de temps ça
parlait dans cette pièce pas trop
longtemps mais assez pour laisser la
crainte d'oublier un petit peu ce qu'on
a vu parce que dans la vraie vie
évidemment si vous assistez à quelque
chose même si ce n'est pas un crime
d'ailleurs quand tu raconte ce qui s'est
passé hier entre les deux potes que tu
as vu un petit peu de délai qui semble
assez et le cerveau pour stocker il rend
les choses cohérent donc il englobe des
situations eu tire des conclusions puis
à la fin j'étais juste fait le récap
pour que tu me valide des choses ou pas
et si c'est assez marrant parce que plus
je te faisais insisté sur des choses
plus fois tu confirmais soit tu doute
est ce dû changer d'avis et il ya aussi
un côté des positions dans la police
mais même une histoire qu'on va raconter
plusieurs fois on va nous demander plein
de détails on va commencer à changer
parce qu'on doute entre ce qu'on a vu la
première fois ce qu'on a entendu et le
fait de ces de s'être entendues soi même
le répéter en les imaginant du coup on
s'est plu à temps c'est un truc que je
viens de dire où qui s'est dit avant et
puis après il ya le fonctionnement de la
mémoire en lui même qui fait qu'on
marche avec des populations de neurones
et on va englober des choses on n'a
jamais dit le mot fruits ok on a on n'a
jamais vu une mob fruits on n'a jamais
dit le mot alcool c'était la même
mécanique en place à ces deux là j'ai
essayé de faire fonctionner en fait
d'aider
des populations mémoire qui sont
connectés ouï dire que pomme à un lien
dans ces cent mille synapses avec le mot
banane avec le mois fruit avec
l'expression cinq fruits et légumes par
jour et c'est en fait ton cerveau à
compléter donc pour lui il a commencé à
valider tu avais un doute en fait au
début mais c'est après quand je t'ai
demandé de confirmer où tu t'es dit non
merci ça c'est dit par contre pas de
molécule cette micro erreur elle montre
que attention on est faillible et on on
peut faire confiance à ce qu'on apprend
mais quand on compte quand on restitue
une scène qu'on a vu on peut pas être
fiable à 100% il faut jamais croire que
c'est parce qu'on est sûr et certain
qu'on a raison
pourquoi c'est si difficile de faire
confiance à sa mémoire pour deux raisons
majeures la première c'est que la
mémoire assemble des informations sous
forme de réseaux connectés c'est comme
ça que les associations d'idées
fonctionne ensuite si je parle de sable
vous allez penser tout de suite aux
vacances à la chaleur la mer au repos et
c'est parce que ces neurones sont
reliées entre les uns les autres ensuite
parce que la mémoire épisodique a
surtout besoin de quelque chose de
simple et de cohérent à stocker par la
suite lorsque vous raconter une
conversation que vous avez eue avec
quelqu'un d'autre vous ne dites jamais
vraiment la vérité vous inventez la
conversation en fonction des
informations globales dont vous vous
souvenez vraiment ces deux choses habib
le souvenir initial qui devient alors
votre souvenir sincère mais pas
totalement fiable lors d'une scène de
crime il faut beaucoup beaucoup de
témoins oculaires pour pouvoir recouper
les informations et réussir à déterminer
lesquels sont probablement fiable mais
encore une fois sans en être jamais
certain à 100% dans la prochaine
expérience vous allez vite comprendre
que notre mémoire est à la fois très
puissante et très faillible parce que
oui nous allons tester la vôtre
[Musique]
passons maintenant à une série de petits
tests rapides pour mettre à l'épreuve
votre cerveau attention pour ce premier
jeu vous pouvez couper le son pour le
faire en même temps que nous sans être
perturbé on s'en reparle juste après
vous êtes prêts c'est à vous
le meilleur moyen de travailler sa
mémoire c'est de stimuler ses
différentes mémoires à l'aide du jeu au
caire en jean c'est toujours le et les
jeux de société d'ailleurs c'est le
meilleur truc pour éviter le
vieillissement cognitif tous les jeux
jour même où nos parents ouais à la
limite peut-être la bonne paye parce que
vraiment il ya ou qu'il commet ce jeu là
pu plaire autant de monde pour elle a
lancé la partie en mode automatique et
de barres et revenir la partie fait
c'est un jeu sur le déterminisme on va
commencer par la question décalé je te
pose une question ok tu me dis pas la
réponse de poser une deuxième question
tu me dis la réponse à la première
question je te pose latéraux par exemple
hockey aux enjeux le concret combien
font un lien tu me réponds pas ouais je
sais pas combien tu as demain tu vas me
dire
questions décalées c'est parti comment
tu t'appelles quel animal à une trompe
cyrus avec quel moyen de transport est
venu aujourd'hui l'éléphant qui dort ou
ce soir dtc ou habitent le président de
la république en ce moment chez moi
courant puisqu'il est comment s'appelle
le magasin qui vend des jouets pour
adultes est visé exactement
et du coup je veux pas prendre trop de
ton temps tu vas vous après ce tournage
sex-shops et sikhs et bessat ça paraît
tout bête mais c'est très bon pour la
mémoire à court terme et la mémoire de
travail ok maintenant passe à l'étape
au-dessus ouais deuxième jeu leberger
queens à l'est quelle est la troisième
lettre de l'alphabet est-ce que parfois
mario bros
combien font quatre fois qu'elle est la
capitale mais de manière précise de la
france comment ça va jusque là
c'est une question si nous nous
inquiétons de quelle couleur et le bleu
nous n'allons pas essayer de se mettre
d'accord chocolatines ou pains au
chocolat combien de fois chuck norris at
il compté jusqu'à l'infini
en parlant de mémoire c'était quoi la
réponse à la troisième question et enfin
est ce que tu penses avoir tout bon
nous restituons quand ils le souhaitent
ok pour ces c'est correct oui courait
alors je sais pas à quoi ça correspond
mais j'ai 16 dans ma tête correct c'est
ça qui est génial avec un palais mental
c'est que tu t'en de la question après
été dûment code que la réponse 16 c'est
corey paris oui bien ok bleus oui je
vaux latine c'est une très bonne réponse
des couples
1-2 été acceptée aussi jugé 3 j'ai 23
mais je sais plus ça correspond tu vois
c'est faux ah bon mais on comprend
pourquoi le 3 on y reviendra juste après
alors pourquoi c'est faux c'est quoi la
question certaines tu dis pas oui non ah
oui c'est ok l'on se dise à la troisième
ok ah oui après je l'échangé en fait
c'est 16 et ensuite si vous exactement
bravo oui parce que toi tu à encoder 3
pour la troisième voilà pour la
troisième question en fait après je suis
mais non en fait trop mais parce qu'en
fait le 16 c'est un prof que j'avais qui
s'appelait monsieur sfez
donc j'ai remis mes se fais est donc vue
de ce fait ils parlaient déjà que oui
oui je suis mis ensemble en fait est
troisième et dernier jeu une fois un
chronomètre s'il vous plaît d'une minute
on va simuler que je passe une commande
dans un resto ouais tu la retient pour
moi ok parce que je vais aux toilettes
ok toi tu vas faire des trucs sur ton
téléphone mais en fait ça va être les
questions que je me posais pour te
perturbé et perturber la concentration
et à la fin le serveur arrive et il faut
que tu restitue la commande
là je vais aux toilettes je vais prendre
des yeux maillot un steak tartare
du reblochon une mousse au chocolat avec
une grande eau gazeuse
dit moissac mots qui finissent par g
instagram
g est acceptée pas grave hockey kg grave
hectos g des six graves ou quoi parfait
quels vêtements tu portais avant-hier
avant-hier je portais j'avais un
pantalon noir et en os je devais avoir
un t-shirt bas un tir de la mer choix de
marc sway dont on ne se souvient pas
il ne faut pas dire fontaine
pourquoi dans trois petits points
j'attends la suite de cette expression
connue à son expression connue fait
vraiment en d'extradition je suis rien
ne sert de courir il faut partir à point
absolument pas l'expression il faut pas
dire fontaine je ne boirai pas tout ah
oui ok tiens belga le serveur qui arrive
tu peux me redonner à commande ouais
bien sûr alors cédé le maillot un steak
tartare bien sûr un peu de roubles au
show
du
moustique mousse au chocolat oui et de
l'eau gazeuse sépare félicitations c'est
un sans faute et là tu as utilisé quand
même 4 mémoires différentes mémoires de
travail donc je t'ai donné la commande
était capable de le stocker là tu es
capable d'utiliser la mémoire du langage
pour retrouver les mots en g toujours
sans abîmer la mémoire de travail tu
étais capable d'aller dans la mémoire
épisodique pour savoir comment était
habillé hier et toujours sans détruire
les items de mémoire de travail et était
capable d'utiliser la mémoire sémantique
pour retrouver la fin de l'expression
donc on peut utiliser en plus différents
types de mémoire en même temps sans
abîmer un stockage temporaire et ça je
vous en parle plus maintenant
une fois qu'on a compris que l'on a
plusieurs types de mémoire on peut alors
les stimuler indépendamment les unes des
autres pour obtenir un résultat
différent nous avons tendance à
focaliser sur la mémoire de travail et
la mémoire sémantique le mémoire
sémantique permet par exemple de retenir
vos connaissances elles s'organisent
elles aussi sous forme de réseau ce qui
explique les erreurs dans la deuxième
expérience sachez que vous n'oubliez
jamais ce qu'il ya dedans en réalité
l'information non utilisés se détache du
système et vous n'arrivez plus à y
accéder mais elle est encore présente
c'est tout à fait différent pour une
mémoire optimale il faut donc travailler
ses différents types de mémoire il y a
également la mémoire procédurale
perceptive etc et lutter contre la
courbe d'oubli en utilisant par exemple
un système de flash cards pour info j'ai
créé ma propre méthode en 2017 qui
s'appelle la memory boxe je vous
mettrais un lien vers la vidéo dans la
description qui vous permet de créer une
bimbo reebok sens de l'acheter
[Musique]
j'ai souvent parlé d'une technique qui
s'appelle la table de rappel c'est un
système très performant qui vous permet
d'utiliser votre mémoire épisodique et
votre mémoire sémantique à la place de
votre mémoire de travail ce qui veut
dire qu'au lieu de stocker cette
information au maximum pendant quelques
secondes vous pouvez stocker jusqu'à une
centaine d'informations durant des jours
voir durant des semaines vous elle la
prendre instantanément avec cyrus et je
vous dirai après comment l'augmenter et
surtout comment vous en servir pour un
petit peu tout
nous allons parler de la table de rappel
ne connais pas du tout c'est ça qui est
trop bien il ya vraiment 3 outil majeur
pour la mnémotechnique en tout cas pour
les mines et moniste c'est le palais
mental tu vas y tu maîtrises c'est la
mnémotechnique on connaît tous tu vas
mais où est donc andy car et puis la
table de rappel qui est l'ardent coder
des chiffres dans sa tête en images à sa
chute dans l'eau parce que genre tous
les numéros digicode du mot téléphone
etc afin d'en faire même si tu sais pas
ce que c'est tu t'en sers déjà un petit
peu parce que tu t'en es servi sur le
burger quiz là tout à l'heure avec 16
avec 16 tu l'a transformé spontanément
en une image donc qu'il y avait un son
approchant comme ça tu te dis je vais
pas l'oublier voici la table de rappel
que je vous propose elle est très simple
à retenir et à l'utiliser plusieurs
systèmes de construction de table de
rappel hockey en on va dire que c'est la
tour eiffel pourquoi parce que la tour
eiffel ça ressemble un aucun grand truc
droit bien falic en deuxième il signe
alors celui ci ressemble pas tellement
d'ailleurs mais un signe comme l'écrit
le chiffre 2 on peut voir un signe 3 un
choeur pascal inférieur à 3 c'est le
syndicat exactement en quatre une
planche à voile parce que quand tu
dessines à 4 comme ça donne l'impression
d'avoir une planche en bois donc là tu
vois on a utilisé toutes les formes pour
ça le 5 le serpent c'est un peu pareil
pour -5 ça peut me faire penser un
serpent là on change de système en 6 1 6
1 un peu comme pour ton prof tout à
l'heure en scène une canne là c'est ce
visuel exactement en 8 des lunettes
c'est bon parce qu'on à l'infini qui ici
à 909 ça c'est le plus logique et le
plus basique 10 police c'est pour la
rime elle peut aussi construire juste
avec elle comme ça dix polices ok on se
satisfait de guitry ça dépend de tout à
chacun en onze du bronze tu dis ouais
mais je visualise ça comme un bonze
d'après tu peux tu peux rajouter des
étapes c'est pas gênant pour moi en 11
dans ma table de rappel principal c'est
le penseur de rodin ah oui et tu vois
quand je pense à 11 bronze dont j'ai
immédiatement l'image du penseur de
rodin que je mets à la place moi je m en
naîtront je pense couler un bronze c'est
pas mal ça marche et sans solde actif
en 12 pelouse la rime et en 13 une
fraise larry tu te souviens tout à
l'heure il y avait les mots que tu
écrivais et que tu dessines et c'était
la première expérience aujourd'hui je
vais te les faire encodés en terminera
là dessus ok avec merci beaucoup mode
avec la table de rappel donc là c'est
l'utilisation la plus classique et la
plus efficace de la table de rappel je
vais te dire en un il y avait une
échelle et dans ta tête une débrouille
pour mettre une échelle sur la tour
eiffel tu es prêt ouais ok en un une
échelle ok tra je sais pas quelle image
faire
en deux un nuage en trois un livre en
quatre un cintre tuque rouge 1,5 il
valises en 6 une paire de ciseaux en 7 1
au grand huit un kayak en neuf des
lunettes
ça ça tue quand tu tombes sur des images
sont déjà dans ta table rappel en dise
une trompette en 11 une fenêtre ok
j'imagine doublage de bois qui jettent
de la merde par la fenêtre vraiment en
douze un poisson et en 13 une règle ok
est ce que tu peux me faire la
restitution en disant un bla bla bla de
blabla bloqué donc en une échelle tout à
fait en deux nuits à absolument en trois
un livre c'est exact en quatre un cintre
oui en 5 une valise oui en 6 des ciseaux
oui en 7 1 au grand oui à 8 du kayak oui
en neuf des lunettes oui jolly en dise
trompette en 11 fenêtre oui en douze
poissons oui et en treize règles oui
jusque là aucune différence avec le
palais mental y avait quoi en neuf ans
neuf il y avait l'une est oui y avait
quoi en 13 ans 13 il y avait une règle
oui le 2 c'était lequel le de ces nuages
d'accord le cintre et en combien le
centre et en quatre la fenêtre était en
la fenêtre elle était en 11 est-ce que
tu te sens puissant parce que c'est pas
incroyable d'avoir tu as tout le
séquençage après du pearl à lille tu
perds le côté linéaire de tracter une
histoire ou de prendre un palais mandral
avec la possibilité comme ça de
dissocier des informations et de pouvoir
y aller que je te dise le mot tu trouves
le chiffre 6 sud odile chiffres tu
trouves le mot se rappelle quand même
qu'il ya quelques secondes tu savais pas
ce que c'était une table de la rappelle
forcément
note stable
j'espère vraiment que vous l'avez fait
en même temps que nous car cette table
de rappel de niveau 13 va vous servir
toute votre vie vous pouvez créer la
vôtre de table en caux dans les chiffres
et les nombres comme vous le souhaitez
vous pour ça je vous recommande soit le
major système très efficace ou
simplement de créer celle qui vous parle
le plus je vous mettrai des liens vidéos
pour ça dans la description ça vous
permettra de vous guider un petit peu
avec cette table vous pouvez retenir un
numéro de téléphone une liste de courses
mais plus simplement tout ce que vous
voulez imaginez que vous avez un exposé
d'histoire à faire en 10 parties et que
vous n'avez pas le droit d'avoir des
notes avec vous pendant l'exposé si la
partie si c'est par exemple sur
l'économie du pays alors vous pouvez
simplement imaginer une liasse de
billets en train de se faire ciller en
faisant comme ça vous n'oublierez jamais
où vous en êtes pendant l'exposé alors
c'est un exemple le simple mais c'est
surtout pour vous montrer que c'est
ensuite à vous de vous approprier
l'outil table de rappel
merci à tous les participants à toute
l'équipe à sherlock smile est un peuple
d'haïti dans la production à loïc à la
réal avec toutes les équipes et bien sûr
à cyrus n'hésitez pas à découvrir ces
vidéos le lien est dans la description
le prochain épisode de matière grise
sera publiée le mois prochain et il va
parler du mensonge vous pouvez vous
abonner gratuitement à cette chaîne si
cette série vous plaît comme ça vous
manquerez pas les prochains épisodes
vous avez également tous les anciens
épisodes de la première saison de
matière grise dans la description alors
notre mémoire et l infini
arriverons-nous à mieux comprendre notre
cerveau pour mieux l'utiliser vous
saurez tout cela et bien plus dans les
prochains épisodes de matière grise à
très bientôt ciao
[Musique]